>> ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
LIBERTIES WHEN THEY COME TO
CONFLICT.
135 THOUSAND DOLLARS AFTER THEIR
BAKERY DECLIMBED MAKE A WEDDING
MELISSA AND AARON CLINE SAID
THEY WERE DECLINED OF RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY AND FREE SPEECH.
HOW DO WE FIND THAT BALANCE WHEN
EVERYBODY RIGHTS WANT TO BE
RAPID.
ROBERT THE GENERAL COUNCILLOR
AND CENTER FOR AMERICAN FUTURE
REQUEST ROBIN BURROW AN ACT VIV
IN AN ARMY RANGER VETERAN
IN@LANCEA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
PROTECTING THE UNITED STATES AND
YOUR SERVICE WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT.
I WANT TO START WITH ROBERT
ISSUE OPPOSED TO WHAT ROBIN WILL
ARGUE WHICH IS DINNER THAN THAT.
WHY DOES RELIGIOUS LIBERTY IN
THE FIRST AMENDMENT TRUMP WHAT
IS GOING ON HERE?
>> JASON THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME THE ISSUE IS WHETHER THE
JUDICIARY SHOULD CONSTITUTE
EXPRESSION IT IS UNCHARTED FOR
OREGON APPELLATE COURT GOT IT
WRONG WHEN THEY DECIDED THE
ARTIST REAL EXPRESSED BY MRS.
CLINE AND HER CUSTOM CAKES WERE
NOT ENTITLEED FIRST AMENDMENT
WHY THEY HAD WHAT THEY WERE
LOOKING TO.
ARGUING ANDMENTING TO APPEAL IS
GOING TO BE BASED ON THE FIRST
AMENDMENT ISSUE.
>> THE WAY THEY GOT AROUND THAT
IN GOING INTO THE PUBLIC DOCKET
REASON THAT LOOKS AT ORDINARY
BUSINESSES IN COMMERCE AS BRICK
AND MORTAR OPERATIONS THAT FALL
OUTSIDE OF TYPICAL FIRST
AMENDMENT FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION
COURT DID THAT TO GET TO THE END
CLINE'S BUSINESS WAS NOT AN
ORDINARY BAKERY IT WAS A SERVICE
AND EXPRESSION SHE DID USING HER
HANDS AND CREATING THE CAKES
WHICH WAS THE WAY SHE EXPRESSED
HERSELF AND THE CONSTITUTION IS
CLEAR THE FIRST AMENDMENT
AS YOU LOOK HOW DO YOU SEE IT MY
GUESS IS YOU GOT A DIFFERENT
TAKE ON THAT.
>> I DO AND THANK YOU FOR
DOLLAR BECAUSE THE BAKEERS
DOCKED THE INDIVIDUALS DECLINED
SERVICE THEY PUT THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION OUT ATTACKED THEIR
CHILDREN TURNED THEM TO CPS AND
THEY WERE VILIFIED THEM.
THIS IS NOTHING TO DO WITH
AMERICAN.
I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT I SEE
IT AS AN IDENTITY POLICY ISSUE
ON THE SIDE OF THE RIGHT.
LBG T AMERICANS WOULD TO BE
TREATED LIKE ANYBODY.
THIS IS WANTING TO BE TREATED
THE SAME.
WE WOULD LIKE TO STOP THIS
IDENTITY POLITIC ISSUE OF BEING
SINGLED OUT I'M A GAY ARMY RANGE
ARE MY BUDDIES NEVER TREATED ME
DIFFERENT AS LONG AS A SHOT
FINE, NOBODY CARED.
>> DO YOU KNOW THAT WELL IS
ROOM FOR RELIGIOUS LIBERTY.
IF IT IS A LONG STADDING TRUE
BELIEF IN THERE RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY WHY CAN'T THEY MAKE THIS
DECISION?
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION I'M GLAD
YOU POSE TODAY.
THERE IS A CASE IN COLORADO A
CUSTOMER WANTED A CAKE IN THE
FIRST MA'AM ISSUE.
BAKER SOLD THEM THE CAKE AND THE
BAG OF ICING AND SAID THEY COULD
WRITE WHEN THEY WANTED TO ON IT.
THAT IS WHERE THE LINE IS.
THIS IS ABOUT DISCRIMINATION THE
PEOPLE WERE TOLD THEY WERE NOT
GOING TO BE SERVED BECAUSE THEY
WERE GAY.
I UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT THAT
WHY GIVE A HOMO PHOBIC BAKER
IT IS NOT OKAY.
WE ARE ALL MENSHES PLEASE MOVE.
I PASSED IDENTITY POLITICS.
NO ONE CARES I'M GAY AND THIS
RELIGIOUS BAKER HAS NO RIGHT TO
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY AND THIS KAES
IS GOING TO BE DECIDED BY THE
SUPREME COURT.
THERE IS A DIFFERENT CASE
PENDING BEFORE THE COURT,
CORRECT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS OREGON CASE THE CLINE CASE
WILL BE A FOOTNOTE A CONSEQUENCE
MASTERPIECE CAKE SHOP CASE.
IN THE ORAL ARGUMENTS BEFORE THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT THE JUSTICE S
U.S. SUPREME COURT THE JUSTICESS
U.S. SUPREME COURT THE JUSTICES
KENNEDY AND ROBERTS WERE TALKING
ABOUT WHERE THIS TENSION EXISTS.
IN THE TUG-OF-WAR WITH THE TWO
SIDES.
AND HOW THEY ARE GRABBLING WITH
THAT ISSUE.
THE OREGON APPELLATE COURT
AVOIDD THAT ISSUE AND SHOE
HORNED MRS. CLINE'S ARTIST REAL
TO THE PUBLIC DOCTRINE IN TERPS
OF A BRICK AND MORTAR BUSINESS
THE PROBLEM IS THE MASTERPIECES
SHE CREATED WERE HER FORM OF
EXPRESSION AND SHE IS ENTITLED
TO FIRST AMENDMENT PROTECTION
FOR THAT ESPECIALLY THAT IS AN
EXPRESS OF HER DEEP LY
EXPRESS OF HER DEEP L
EXPRESS OF HER DEEPLY
EXPRESS OF HER DEEPLY H
EXPRESS OF HER DEEPLY HEL
EXPRESS OF HER DEEPLY HELD
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS.
ROBIN I WILL GIVE YOU THE LAST
WORD
>> PLEASE, TREAT US THE SAME.